[Music]
[Applause]
the lakers host golden state on saturday
night dan wiki covers the nba covers the
lakers for the la times all right where
do you want to start here dan with what
happened last night
um it's been great theater dan i just
want to say
thank you
you know you know you say you want to
watch the struggle like that's the crazy
thing is like they have seven more games
on national tv as as the season plays
out right like so we are all going to
see this like it is very public
um i mean i think i mean russ is as good
a place to start as any because that
decision impacted everything um not just
in terms of what he's able to do on the
court
sort of the the math problems it caused
for them when you trade
three players for one um when that
player makes 43 million dollars and
that's money you can't spend elsewhere
uh you know i was watching in that third
quarter and you watched that you know
the the clippers going i think it was
like a 23-0 run at one point and you
look around it's like why can't this
team stop anybody and you you realize oh
well kyle kuzma and tavia's cobble pope
are on a different team alex caruso is
on a different team like these are the
guys that were parts
of the pillars of the identity that the
lakers won a title with which was built
on defense and that has all been traded
out that has all been gone in an effort
to be more dynamic on offense and they
stink on offense
and they're
slightly below average on defense and
that's why they are in the position
they're in
tim legler was on yesterday and he said
that he's watching the body language and
he said during timeouts they're not
talking to each other like there's no
spirit there there's nobody who's sort
of
you know getting in somebody's face here
and they've they've had those players in
previous years they just don't have that
now but i i wonder
what do you do in the offseason
um a lot right and i think i think legs
is right um you know i think what we're
seeing right then is you're seeing a
team that had
championship expectations
uh being confronted with the reality and
they might not even be the top best team
in the west you know and that's it's
jarring and it has been
you know let's wait like you said we'll
wait to the end of december this has
been their approach on a lot of things
at least publicly it's like well let's
wait and see where we're at once we're
healthy let's wait and see where i want
to get some continuity um you know here
we are with 20 games left in the season
and it doesn't seem uh it seems it was
impossible to imagine that they'll get
either of those things um
as far as the off season goes
you know it
dealing with the russell westbrook issue
um seems like it'll be at the very top
of the list right um best for both
parties i think probably to
figure out a solution now that that's
gonna it's gonna like the lakers are
gonna have to pay for that it's not a
simple like let's find a team that wants
russ like they're gonna have to sweeten
that deal they're gonna have to use
draft picks to kind of start to dig out
of the hole that they're in but they've
probably got to dig out of the hole and
then i think secondarily um you know a
coaching change seems likely the lakers
have kind of said that
um
you know with with a half-hearted
extension
um with kind of letting frank vogel
dangle a little bit here during during
this season i mean they've sort of made
their their feelings known there and i
think
um again another situation problem for
best for both parties
um you know like there's going to be big
there'll be big changes this team has to
look differently next year dad here's
the crazy thing i'm not convinced
they'll look that much better
well i wonder if um lebron knows the
clock is ticking he wants to win at
least one more championship and he's got
to look around and go
can i win a champ do you think lebron
can win a championship in in the next
couple of years there in los angeles
i mean now without a certain level of
luck that hasn't been there right like i
mean you're gonna need he's gonna have
to continue to defy age on the court but
he's gonna have to stay on the floor
right um
you know lebron has missed a lot of time
this year uh his his running mate is
anthony davis and so you need anthony
davis on the court like these are big
ifs when you talk about the lakers if
anthony davis was healthy if lebron
james keeps playing at this level
i mean you know next season lebron will
be 38
you know um the year up to that will be
39 and eventually you would think like
that i mean maybe we're already starting
to see some of those things slow down
you know the swollen knee
um you know the ankle injuries seem kind
of freakish but you know he's had other
things a groin injury that he's dealt
with like the soft tissue injuries that
tend to kind of suggest older age you
know um i think
i think that is obviously those are huge
gifts
can it happen i mean they have a
puncher's chance i mean they are i was
talking to a scout last night and it's
like they are as born on third base of a
team as anybody right because they have
lebron james and anthony davis and it's
sort of why despite all of this stuff
you talk to teams around the league
nobody still wants to play them they
don't want to see them in the play and
they don't want to see them in the first
round of the playoffs because they have
these two guys and these two guys are
unquestionably great players uh is this
a great team um no not close
handicapped the rest of the west here
best team is who
i i think at full health i think it's
the phoenix suns but the chris paul
thumb injury is an interesting one um it
is a that team to me when i see them
they make the most sense
um like you just see them they've got
athletic wings now they have x they have
experience they have perimeter scoring
they have an interior presence they've
got tremendous depth
they've been there before it's a team i
really like
um
i i still sort of think the utah jazz
are lurking and they they've
disappointed the playoffs so many times
um but but you know it's a terrific
offense
and and you know a team that's played
much better basketball seemingly the
only team the lakers can be weirdly
enough is the utah jazz but but you know
you're talking to everybody that doesn't
seem like a problem they'll have to
conquer the playoffs
you know and and then obviously the
warriors are the warriors i mean i think
steph curry's in a little bit of a funk
right now um klay thompson's still
playing his way back and and
reintegrating pieces like that is not
easy dan it it like it especially
especially when it's been so long it's
hard to readjust your identity like that
uh but again that's just another team
that i think you know uh is in the mix
it's just to me phoenix just feels like
they have the least amount of questions
a thumb injury isn't the end of the
world chris paul will be back on the
court at some point um he'll be able to
stay in shape it's not like you can't
jog if you have a broken bum it's not
like you can't work out a little bit and
stuff like that so i don't think it'll
be hard for him to kind of to get back
running at full speed make a case for
john moran to win mvp
um
the memphis grizzlies aren't on
anybody's radar if he's not like
jumping above the backboard every game
you know like in terms of value they're
a game out of the two seed right now
yeah yeah yeah again he is the value
case right um and i you know i i didn't
mention memphis and i probably should
because it's easy to to kind of see
um the path for them right like it is
kind of a weird year again in the west
you know who knows um what doors will be
open they're tremendously athletic
another team with tremendous depth uh
they've never been there before which is
always it's tough to go through it the
first time and we'll see
what you know how how a team defends
john moran over 77 game series is
totally different from how you deal with
him on a night tonight basis and how
good are they at adjusting but i there's
probably not a more exciting player in
the league right now um it does feel
like he can do anything i was in the
building when you know he he blocked
that shot against the lakers and it
looked like you know he had a you know a
couple tesla rockets and the sneakers
like it's he
he is like sort of one of those guys
when you when you open your phone or you
turn on league pass or whatever it's
anything is certainly possible and on a
team like that
at this stage i mean what who could be
more valuable in that sense
yeah i don't know it's like most
outstanding as far as best highlights
sure or because giannis has won a couple
it feels like it's embiid's turn even
though the joker's played well with the
denver team that's you know been missing
some players there
i i i always i'm always curious about
this meteoric rise like luca had a
meteoric rise but he didn't win the mvp
because the team wasn't good enough
john moran is having that meteoric rise
and they're playing like there's
validation in his value to them whereas
luke i said he's not going to be an mvp
anytime soon until they get better
yeah you know it's it's i'm glad at the
only times like we don't vote on awards
which is like luckily it's something i'm
glad i don't do it um to be totally
honest like it is
it is a tricky it is a tricky thing to
kind of figure this out because another
name we haven't mentioned is demar
derozan
you know who has been
again
you talk about the team on a quick
meteoric rise and he's the type of
person that i think voters want to
reward because
it's such a good story it's such a good
like kind of out of nowhere seemingly
season but it's hard to vote an mvp with
a hot you can't say oh remember that
time in that game against
like you know the joker had sort of a
season like that last year but he had
some unbelievable passes
uh demar derozan like here's another
team winners couple game winners all
right okay
yeah but but look dan they've got to
beat you know and this is an issue and
they haven't beaten good teams that's
what i was just going to say they've got
to beat really good teams yeah and they
just haven't done it so i mean i think
to me like right now if i was filling a
ballot i would look at embiid i would
look at jokic and i would look at
morant probably closest and then giannis
is like right on the edge of that and
then you just start to
it at a certain point it becomes a level
of taste like those guys have all been
so good
um embiid has been has been great on
both sides of all what jokic is doing
is still like kind of rewriting
possibilities in offense giannis um you
know is maybe the most dominant player
in the nba and then you've got this guy
john morant who
like i said i mean like seems like sort
of a mix of like
allen iverson and derek rose a little
bit like pre-injury is kind of who i
always see and it's just sort of
you know it really does feel like he is
he's on the precipice of something
really really special that's the crazy
thing with him dan is like are we even
seeing the best of him right now like
like how much more is there to go
bill orem of the athletic got yelled at
by lebron have you been yelled at by
lebron
i'm snarled at certainly not to that
extent i i i will say this i have yelled
at delorme before
lebron snarled at you
absolutely yeah what was snarl worthy
i think you know i mean i think there
was a point at the time during the
season where he basically looked over
and was like you keep asking the same
questions
right like you keep asking us
and we don't know and if we did know we
would maybe answer but you should have
said hey you guys keep playing the same
way that's what i told him
frustrating um like we're trying we're
trying jennifer i pulled the cj mccollum
card you know i mean i think that
you know certainly the uh
um you know the the bill lebron
situation obviously like a a little jest
in there too and stuff it's just
everybody's frustrated dan like honestly
like it is a it is a very tiring team
um to be around and what i mean by that
is that it's just like i said like this
is a team that i think
you know you heard them talk about
championships you know with a straight
face through december um we heard
russell westbrook talk about a
championship last night
uh you know saying like the season's not
over our goals are still in front of us
and it's you know you're eight games
under 500
and um you know
why are you even talking about anything
beyond
you know winning a single game playing
better than one quarter um like this
team hasn't figured that out yet and
it's
it is a little bit exhausting constantly
trying to
dissect these huge big picture issues
right like these aren't little tiny
problems these are big problems that
they're trying to tackle but like at the
same time like they're not even getting
like the the day-to-day results that
painting uh
a tribute to ferris bueller's day off
yes it's uh you know i'm a chicago and
my son is named cameron um you know it
is a uh
it is high art in my room dan so you
didn't want to go with ferris as a name
for your son
no i didn't want i didn't want like
people thinking you know like say ferris
and stuff like that cameron underrated
character um i don't know why he's a red
wings fan it never made total sense to
me and maybe if they're in a prequel or
a sequel that would ever get addressed
but uh yeah you know i mean but
everything about cameron he was an
outsider
yeah and and he worked his way into like
the the popular social circle a real
hero in my opinion
and
unlike me a father with a great car
dan great to talk to you good luck the
rest of the season
thank you enjoy the struggle yes dan
winky he covers the lakers and nba for
the la times